thanks everybody for coming today this
is my very first Python talk I'm used to
giving scientific talks so sorry if I'm
a little terse or anyway can everyone
hear me fine great okay so I'm going to
talk today about a modeling framework
that we've developed at sunpower that
we're calling carousel and this is a
carousel and like somebody I said my
name is Mark makovsky and I'm from
sunpower corporation so a little bit
about me uh my handle is bona Marco I
spent a couple years in Tanzania in the
Peace Corps bwana in Swahili means mr.
and there they like all your names to
end in a vowel so I became Marco and I
kind of liked it so it's duck breaking
bites is kind of more for technical
stuff so that my friends don't get in
none dated with really geeky stuff they
hate that and then I have this really
ridiculous blog so i did my PhD at UC
berkeley and I've been doing numerical
modeling for a really long time I don't
know if I'm very good at it but it's
really fun I like it and currently I'm
at sunpower where I'm the architect of
our performance prediction and in this
context performance has nothing to do
with like servers or websites or
anything here we're specifically talking
about the how much energy our PV systems
produce so SunPower holds the Guinness
Book world's record for commercially
available pv panels pv stands for
photovoltaic we've been doing that for
over 30 years we do residential
commercial utility scale we've installed
over two gigabyte gigawatts worldwide
and I think this is a really cool
picture this is the Solar Impulse 2
which is the first solar-powered
airplane to fly all the way around the
world and it completed that on July 28
this year and that's the Golden Gate
Bridge and it was entirely powered by
sunpower solar cells they're spaced
contraindicated
have used gallium arsenide which is very
expensive option but they chose haven't
awesome so here's my agenda and I'll try
to keep on time so I'll start off with
talking about our requirements and some
of the challenges that we face then I'll
introduce carousel and then I'll give a
little bit of a demo though it's kind of
vague I'm going to preface this with the
disclaimer that carousel is very much
pre-release and i'll talk about roadmap
last and then I'll give a quick plug for
the uncertainty wrapper and I'll just
set the tone here the overall goal of
this talk is to encourage collaboration
we decided to go this route we saw that
there was a absence and you know we
couldn't find something to meet this
need so that's why we're kind of
developing this but we don't want to go
alone we think that a lot of people
could really benefit from this and you
know we benefit as well so we all
benefit all right so challenges and
requirements for model simulation I
don't know for on time or not LT Clark
but so what kind of models are we
talking about here so I work at a solar
power company and we have existing
projects and we have proposed projects
and all of those projects we need to
know how much energy are they going to
make every single year for 30 years is
kind of the amortized lifetime of a
power plant or you know your rooftop
whatever and so this is a really large
model it has many factors in my company
factors is what we call dimensions many
mathematical expressions and then
there's even conditions within those
expressions when you use this expression
when you use that expression you know
for example to you have a snow load win
load whatever so it's pretty complicated
and it's in production over a thousand
users I know this is very small from you
know ecommerce kind of like a million
people clicking but we have over a
thousand users every day these are
dealers these are salesmen these are
researchers coming up with new cell
technology
so this is not a little analytical
Jupiter notebook that you can like pass
around this is a web application that
you go to and you use so that also kind
of sets the tone for carousel in general
I think it's really applicable for large
scale projects that span you know a long
time and many users I can see how you
might use this for smaller projects but
I don't necessarily think i would
recommend it so what does SunPower need
uh well bottom line is we need a
bankable model something that we can
show to investors and say this is how
much energy it produces well how did you
calculate that well we have this model
it's transparent it's tested it's
documented it's stable it's fast it's
all these things right but we're always
coming up with new technologies you know
now we're coming up with a new type of
module we had a new type of module new
cell technology that just come came up a
few years ago we have new tracker system
so we need to be we need a turnkey
approach to rapidly develop maintain
update these models like you know fast
we need to train new people so you know
we have a little churn little turnover
people come in people come out we expand
we can track solar business is kind of a
touch and go I think we're here to stay
but it's still you know a tough place to
be in and we also have collaborators
people who are using our API they want
to use our software and they're like how
to use this we're like we don't know and
then we want to integrate with those
third-party applications so we're
working with tendril tendril makes
applications that talk to your
appliances they say turn on the
refrigerator turn off the refrigerator
turn on the AC turn it off turn on the
TV whatever so we needed a approach that
considered the overall modeling and not
just the specifics so these are some of
the challenges of the current state it's
funny I've been hearing all these talks
and Tracy yesterday was talking about
for software carpentry how you know the
is will be this modeler or data
scientist kind of like the lone wolf in
the room it's like are using kit what's
good auto doe you know and so um raise
your hand if you've ever experienced any
of these maybe we'll bond you know like
my kids do you know we're connecting so
there were several coding paradigms and
styles and they were all mixed together
with no common guidelines anyone ever
experienced that okay a hundred percent
of the code was proprietary zero of the
code was from open source all right uh
boilerplate procedures were repeated
over and over and over again and there
was no leveraging of reusable code so
this is good no unit tests profiling and
debugging with like finding a needle in
a haystack implementing new features so
so the rest of this kind of goes into
like what this kind of causes right so
implementing new features making updates
and bug fixes they're really difficult
and sometimes error-prone anybody have
that problem you're like I want to make
this change but I think I have to make
it in four places and I'll just search
the entire code base for this keyword
and see maybe this keyword + S or this
keyboard + lib or something like that
it's like oh there there I never thought
it was there anyway um thank God for
github right no one knew all of the code
well so this makes training new modelers
and collaborators kind of tough there's
nobody's an expert and and this is kind
of what caused this issue right and I
think this comes from a business culture
we heard about this from Peter Wang
yesterday this concept that there there
are software developers and there are
data scientists or scientists or
researchers right you guys don't mix
together you know data scientists could
never make a django website oh don't own
right that's we get corporate IT you
just start working on that stuff okay so
we put together a spec for this model
right it's like okay the spec will have
a PV panel and the PV panel will have
parameters and there
will be an inverter and we'll connect
those together and we'll calculate the
power right it's very 200-page spec
nowhere in there did it talk about the
overall architecture nowhere in there
did it say will be extensible it will
have unit testing it will have auto
documentation it will use source control
blah blah blah no never thought it so I
tried to tell this as a story i was in
reliability where I was working on
degradation and the changing trajectory
here a little bit and the R&T guys were
like we want a model that can predict
degradation and we want to be able to
throw any formula at any time we feel
like it and change through output
reporting we want to report for the CEO
for these people right I was like gosh
how am I going to do this I don't know
so I might be jumping ahead a little bit
I'm jumping at let's stick here ok so
I'll come back to that story later so
we're trying to solve this problem and
so we took some approaches we're like
well we'll set in a establish a set of
common guidelines will implement some
best practices will start using open
source will start reusing these
boilerplate snippets all over the place
you know and and it's kind of led us to
think oh well maybe we need some kind of
framework right and not just
requirements for the model and so the
outcome of that was well we'll either
adopt a framework or will develop one
ourselves and we want to do it in a
language that has all the batteries
included as well as a numerical library
that's very strong so obvious choices
Python so now I'll introduce a carousel
and this is where I was talking about
that story so I was like how am I going
to do this degradation model these cell
guys want to be able to put in any
formula any time and a friend of mine
who worked at lbl at nurse he's like
well you should get design patterns
that's the best computer book ever
written ever and I was like so I'm
reading through it I was like wow this
is a really big book how am I going to
read this book right and I get to this
section it's like on page 26 about
frameworks frameworks versus toolboxes
I'm so glad
so I start reading it so this quotes
from that book and if you haven't ever
seen this book I urge you to get it from
the library it's a bit dated but it's
going to be a lot of like oh wow cool oh
I do that too oh that's awesome totally
like that if you have never felt that
you want to feel that read this book and
you you will feel that so the framework
dictates the architecture of your
application it will define the overall
structure its partitioning into classes
and objects the key responsibilities of
those classes and objects and how they
collaborate and controls the the whole
program a little bit more if you go into
Wikipedia about frameworks there's a
couple of distinguishing features that
differentiate them from toolboxes one of
them is inversion of control and a
framework unlike libraries or tool boxes
or normal user applications the overall
programs flow of control is not dictated
by the caller but by the framework right
so pandas is a perfect example right you
can use pandas in a bunch of different
environments and you just kind of like
grab one tool and your you stick
something in you get something up right
framework does the opposite it flips
that model and it says here's what
you're going to put in this room here's
what you're going to put in that room
here's what you're going to put in that
room and then you're just going to call
me and I'm just going to do magic Django
is a perfect example of a framework
Eclipse if you ever use Eclipse as a
framework frameworks are also extensible
so they can be extended in the rationale
for using a framework is the designers
as a software framework aim is to fill
facilitate software development by
allowing designers and programmers to
devote their time to meeting software
requirements rather than dealing with
more standard low-level details of
providing a working system thereby
reducing overall development time
reducing cruft this is what it comes
down to this really resonated with me
when I saw that I was like oh yeah
that's what we need that's what I want
then that solved the problem for the
degradation model and that was this guy
right here PV sim life oh it doesn't
show up on this monitor it shows up on
that monitor probably won't slide over
you all
alright so i made this a long time ago
and so come back to today and we wanted
to do this for our energy production
model and i was like oh i know the
answer let's use a framework and the
like okay mark will try so one more time
plug for design patterns really drive
this home a framework pre defines these
design parameters so that you then the
application designer the implementer the
computer modeler the computer scientist
the data scientists whoever you are you
can concentrate on the specifics of your
application and you don't have to worry
about the cruft not awesome so it's
pre-release carousel whoa okay there
were some existing frameworks obviously
we shouldn't just go into this
willy-nilly what else is out there
already so their existing component
frameworks like Django and flask and
many many many others for web apps and
these quickly became established people
realize on doing the same thing over I'm
doing you know a view or whatever and so
people love these because they they
automate these boilerplate design
patterns and they result in stable
highly performant feature rich web apps
and api's right there were smadav
simulation frameworks to simulink is
obviously the most obvious of them but
they're really focused on rapid
iteration and design and development and
analysis they don't really scale to
production now the mathworks would argue
that's not true we have code generator
we have embedded c we could do this
whatever you want and a lot of people do
go that path but it's expensive and and
if you don't have that much granular
control i mean if you want to go that
way that's awesome do that we didn't
want to do that so we decided well we're
going to have to use care we're going to
have to implement our own and luckily we
had one because i had already done it
for reliability so so we just ported
that over and it became carousel so
carousel defines model components and
controls to simulation it's a framework
and so right now i'm going to talk about
structure
of carousel how it works how you can
make models and where it still kind of
sucks and need some help and and where
it is kind of working for right now so
the way it's structured is it's you have
a big model and models are made up of
layers and I just made up these names if
they don't work for you we can change
them layers are made up of sources and
sources are where you have like the data
the algorithms the instructions whatever
so data input an output that those are
two separate layers they collect data
from various sources and they can report
generate reports they also propagate
units using pint pint has a units
wrapper which is awesome and pint is
very responsive to pull requests and
they also propagate uncertainty which is
kind of like always the elephant in the
room you know you're like the answer is
to what's the uncertainty oh I don't
know could be a hundred percent could be
two hundred anyway so we need to know
that bankers want to know that and data
inputs also have something called data
readers and these are methods for
retrieving data from different documents
you can think of a document as an object
I like to think of that inputs and
outputs is kind of like cereal or
serializers and D serializers it differs
a little bit from like pandas from excel
in that that kind of assumes you already
have a tabular format right but if you
think about it you get a lot of let's
say you get a report from your fab right
and they're like we touched a new cell
you know and it's going to have like the
power and cell b3 and the you know a
table down here and you know CTE you
know 11 to 22 doesn't really fit into
like a standard it's it's it's own
special unique object right and so the
data rate reader would I use pandas from
Excel or could use XLR dior could use
numpy Jen from text whatever and it just
kind of coordinates the arguments so
that you can pass those into a data
reader and you can kind of lock those in
for one particular type of document and
you can recreate it many data readers as
you want and you can make them as
flexible or an arrow as you like there
are formulas these are mathematical
equations in model algorithms so they
can have flow control they can be
ever you want and they're wrapped with
units wrappers and uncertainty wrappers
there's calculations so calculations are
like recipes for something you want to
calculate and basically inputs data and
outputs and formulas they're all
agnostic so you could reuse a formula
many times so for example we have a
rollup formula which is like a pandas
dataframe group by or summation or
something like that and maybe we pass
different arguments into it so we might
roll up energy we might roll up
something else we might want hourly or
weekly so you can reuse that formula
multiple times the calculation is a map
which formula which data map to which
args and what's the return what output
will it not to then models and
simulations simulations is the last
layer it's kind of one of the most
powerful layers it gets access to all of
the other layers and it's where you
provide instructions where you say what
you want to show on screen during a
simulation what do you want to write to
file and there you can also set
thresholds when a calculation should be
done in a dynamic simulation when not I
forgot to mention for calculations
there's two calculators static and
dynamic you can add more calculators and
then the model groups everything
together and then every layer has a
dictionary called a registry and it has
a couple extra methods one of them is
the register method make sure you can't
register something twice and then it
also kind of dictionaries are very flat
so it makes a dictionary a little
lighter so that things can have
attributes and then the way that you
extend carousel is by adding the new
layer so here's kind of a visual of the
model so here's a model here you have
five layers and then in here you have
the sources and some of the things that
are in some of these sources and then
the registries so it's a big visual so
here's how making a carousel model looks
to a user so excuse me we have this
quick start script it's kind of like
sphinx quit star or Django start project
whatever it makes a folder structure for
you may change its like it did from
Django 1.5 to 1.6 who knows and then
what you're going to do and I'll show
some examples later you're going to
create some data subclasses so the way
this all works is by subclassing I
really tried to model this after Jen go
as much as possible to me I see this as
like Django for modelers and Django is
kind of event driven this is kind of
more cereal or there's a dag actually in
there so it figures out what the
dependences are you specify the readers
and then you can declare the structure
do the same for output do the same for
formulas if we're formulas there's
something similar to data reader it's
called a formula importer right now
there's a Python importer and a num
expression importer I kind of foresee
that you could make kernels similar to
Jupiter where you could import from our
or MATLAB or whatever right c would be
really easy to do because there's a capi
then you create your calculation
subclasses your simulation subclasses
any extra parameters you want to
describe can go in adjacent file right
now i'm using jason i realized the mo
might have been better so maybe we'll
use the mo and jason or whatever then
you want to create your model so right
now there's already a basic model so you
could just use that right basic model
has the basic five layers if you wanted
to create a new layer like a validation
layer then you can create a new model
right then you load that model into
carousel and i'll show you how you do
that you basically just call the model
you pass it the parameter file model and
then every model has a commands method
maybe i'll change that to simulate and
you can send the simulation commands
through the command method so you send
your simulation the start community and
it starts how does this look to carousel
on the inside carousels like oh I gotta
load a model okay got that i'm going to
import everything and initialize it the
way you told me to okay now I'll start
going through your layers first I'll
load the data layer I'm going to load
all your data oh you have a data reader
it tells me how to open a file open the
file get all your data make your data
registry next I'll do that for the
output so right now carousel is a little
kind of statically defined you'll notice
that it's pretty rigid this is the
this way to do things in the beginning
and so you need to define your outputs
in advance and actually if you think
about this kind of good from a modeling
perspective right the first thing you
want to know is what do I need to
calculate so think of your output there
you go if you want to add some more
later fine i just did it yesterday
formulas so I'm carousel I loaded your
output it's now unloading your formulas
now load your calculations when i load
your formulas i'll apply the unit
wrappers and the uncertainty wrappers
and i'll create the registry calculation
simulation and then you send me the
start thing well the first thing I'm
going to do is I'm going to check your
calculations and I'm going to make the
direct already forget what it's called
acyclic graph and I'm going to figure
out which ones depend on which and in
your calculations you have to actually
actually state this calculation you know
performance is going to depend on the
Arabians calculation the radiance
calculation doesn't depend on anything
my load shifting algorithm well that
will depend on the performance
calculation in the cost calculation so
it figures that out and then it's going
to do static calculations first those
could be at different times but what
they basically mean is that they're all
independent so they'll do them all at
once boom vectorized then it will do
dynamic calculations dynamics differ in
that right now it only marches over time
but it means that the next time step
depends on the previous one so you could
do it implicitly but that would be a lot
harder generally time you just do
explicit new march and then so I showed
you that PV sim life app that I had made
many many years ago that was a client we
don't have that now right now you do
everything in the main workspace but I'm
going to try to do that again it's just
said I thought that is really funny I
don't know if you guys had who can tell
me what this is you're the only one so
yes I will never use TK okay never ever
ever ever oh but it's so cool isn't it
no um I am a solid believer in
uh using the web now I only use web you
eyes if you have not checked out
bootstrap Twitter bootstrap get
bootstrap I urge you to do it it's
awesome you're going to mind it's going
to be blown then you're going to love
JavaScript and you won't never come back
to a Python conference so um so PV live
demonstration are we okay on time um ok
so PV lib is a is a Python package that
was developed by sandia national labs
and it's it's an amazing open source
tool box this open source revolution is
probably one of the greatest things for
mankind so we're following the package
overview section that's in pd lib and
it's a very basic calculation of annual
pv system energy what you need in order
to run this example is and currently
this only works in my fork so you'd have
to go to github to Makovsky i have a
pull request for this it was working
before and then i made a bunch of
changes in carousel and then it broke
and then i made it work again oh and
also pv lib released a new version 0.4
and they broke their API that's why I to
do bunch of pics so it does work again
so you will need numpy sci-fi a
numerical expression pint we totally
don't follow the dictum that we want to
use as little libraries as possible no
you just have to use all the libraries
we tell you to and that's it and utes on
pi PI and you told so on github so i
encourage you to send us issues and fork
it and send pull requests and there's
also some documentation the
documentation could definitely be better
though the pv sim life documentation was
a lot more thorough but this is just one
hat i wear which is fun so like I said
you're going to call carousel quick
start and then you're going to give your
project a name in this creates a folder
structure under a folder called that
name and then it also creates in there a
Python package that has the same name
but lower case right and that's where
you're going to put all your sub classes
and models
and so we start with the data layer and
you're going to specify you I think in
your mind you kind of have to break up
your program into structures you know
I'm going to have all my radiance data
may be or whether data I'll have all my
pv modules solar panel module specific
data maybe inverter specific data and
maybe I'll have just like a generic
utility data structure and so then you
create data sources based on each one of
those x sub classing data source from
the core carousel package and so just
like django you can declare data
directly in the class as class
attributes and then behind the scenes
carousel uses meta classes to scrape all
those up and make them class attributes
or I guess they already art class entry
but you know what any another way that
you can do them is you can put them in a
JSON file I don't know which is better
the JSON file is kind of nice because
you can change it reloaded with the
class when you'd have to quit Python and
let's start it again whatever and then
all methods right now they just kind of
have this generic prepared data if you
don't want to use this you can just say
pass but you have to have that method
and what that does is like let's say you
know you read and data use the Excel rd
reader you have data in a spreadsheet
and you have like six columns of date
stamps time stamps right year month day
hour minute second this happens to us a
lot so when that matlab does it right
and you want to group that into like a
either a daytime object or daytime
string whatever I so string so you can
put that in prepare data you might also
need to maybe one of your fields might
be a file name so maybe you want to open
that file and read the stuff out into
some data fields to get stick that in
there as well so it's just kind of like
a clean up call and then here are some
of the attributes there's units is
constant which means that in a dynamic
calculation whether or not it should be
indexed at each time step or not
uncertainty and you can name which time
series it's related to so doesn't really
have pandas baked in because panda just
doesn't work well with like the units
wrap
for the uncertainties rapper super well
yet I can get will in the future so
that's kind of how you link to a time
series so here's kind of an example so
I'm in Pierre importing data source from
the carousel core package and then I'm
subclassing it here I'm going to make a
PV module I'm going to state it's going
to use a jangle model reader so it's
going to read this from a jungle model
which I've imported here I I don't want
it to cache data so when you load a
model it can catch the data locally to
make it faster to load next time here I
don't want to do that because I only
Oliver want it to come from Django and
then here are my parameters and I kind
of truncated it and then in my class
meta i'm going to say what model is just
well it's a pv module jungle model and
so now I know it's to go get that from
Django what do I want to exclude a lot
of fields in the Jengo model you can
also as an opposite to exclude you can
say the fields that you want to include
and so there are a lot of other fields
in here there's like a bunch of
coefficients c0 c1 c2 those are just
going to be pulled in automatically but
their attributes will be set to the
default and then here's that prepared
data I'm just going to say pass I don't
need to do anything fancy Val puts
layers really similar to this you just
basically have to say what output you're
going to happen what their attributes
are maybe dynamic sizing will be in the
future and you know these attributes can
change a lot of these are kind of
specific to my needs but I think they
should be more generic the formula layer
formulas can be written as functions in
Python modules or as numerical
expression strings using Python
numerical expressions formulas can be
specific or they can be generic so they
could be used over and over again for
example an integrator right is something
you might need to use over and over
again think of like simulink they have
an integration node right they can be
short or long whatever works for you
they can you know they're great for
wrapping see libraries so if you import
see types you can import a see library
all return values from formulas go into
the output registry all the arguments
can come from either the data registry
or the output reg
answer what recursive uh I think so yeah
definitely I think the only limit on
formulas is that they kind of have to be
stateless so for example in see you see
a lot of times they pass in like a like
a structure and then it'll change it and
you see that the formula doesn't output
anything you're like how did where's the
calculation scope but they didn't see
they went into that structure and then
somebody else is going to get the
structure and the changes will be there
here if you want your changes to
propagate they have to come out from the
return you can and I mean that's by
design basically we want this we want to
separate functions and data so that we
can basically feed this to the cloud to
a bunch of computers have them do
everything and come back yeah yeah you
should check out the pine toolbox it's
awesome so basically let's say your data
is in watts right but your formula wants
to take kilowatts right so you just say
the first argument input is kilowatts
and PI automatically converts it to
kilowatts and then it's drinks the unit
and then your function does it's a
little magic because it doesn't know
what a quantity object is it only knows
what numbers are right and then it spits
it out and then pint grabs and said oh
you said the output should be you know
kilowatt hours per kilowatt boom done
are you happy and so then you never ever
crash a satellite into like Mars again
so uncertainty is
so that that's handled in the
calculation layer so the formula is
think of the formulas as objects there
they're really there like bricks and
they don't really have any brains they'd
just put something in one side and it
comes out the other side yes and and if
you my formulas a lot of times my
formulas are like one line like
literally here i'm using a toolbox that
pv lib toolbox so i'm going to call this
is a clear sky model i need to massage
the data a little bit because it doesn't
like arrays it just wants a scalar so I
take the latitude and longitude and you
know numpy has an item call and so then
I can pass them in and then it spits out
a structure and so I'm going to break
that structure or dictionary up into
pieces and actually it's a panda data
frame and so then now d ni gh I DHI
which are different types of your
radiance can be shoved into the output
registry and then here's the parameter
file that kind of goes with that and
what I'm not showing is in the model
you're also going to stop class formulas
and say you know I'm going to have I
think this is my radiance formula module
and so I would create a new radiance
formula subclass in my model so one
thing I didn't get to talk about here is
uncertainty will talk about it a little
bit more but basically you take in
first-order covariance and you output
first order covariance in Jacobian which
is the sensitivity and it uses this
great formula which is basically
Jacobian jacobians like your
sensitivities times covariance x 2
transpose Jacobian boom first order
linear approximations so it's it's not
perfect but it's it's better than
nothing which is the current state and
its really fast
I'll get to that at the end there's this
one slide on that so calculations again
you're going to subclass calculations
you can declare them in line as class
attributes or in adjacent parameter and
the calculations are an ordered list so
it's like baking right you know makes
the ingredients first and so it's it's a
list and then the next item see if I
have an example of calculations right
yeah so they're split up into static and
dynamic and then basically you have a
formula which formula is it arguments
which arguments come from data so the
frequency argument I mean that's the
hourly data registry item dt dt sdt
start that's the time step stamp start
data registry item so these are all
mapping arguments on the left to the
data registry keys on the right and it
doesn't have anything from the output
this formula down here clear sky uses
time stamps from the output and then the
returns in this case you it's not a map
because this is the name of the return
key in I mean of the output key in the
output registry so shove that into the
output registry shove these into the
output registry and the uncertainty that
goes into the meta side of the registry
so the registry is a dictionary but has
this extra little bit to put more stuff
in then the simulation right now there's
a standalone simulation I'm hoping that
we can create more types of simulations
this is the big conductor right and so
the things you need to specify here are
commands what you want to show on screen
what you want to write and that's pretty
much it it gets access to all the
registries from the model and then you
create the model basically the model is
a list of all your subclasses what
modules and packages there in or path if
you want to load it that way you can you
don't have to give a module one package
consists a bath under the hood we use
the import lib module built in module in
Python
so here is kind of a collapsed version
you have outputs formulas i expanded
formulas so i have three formula
subclasses performances in there that's
the one that have PV module and then for
each one here I like the module package
method really works best for me path is
good if you like to like import a
third-party path later and you haven't
installed it or it's not I'm pythonpath
then you can use the path so it's just
very bad basic and so that's how you
load a model so here I'm going to go to
my project that i created using quick
start and then i'm going to import my
model which is a sandy array performance
model and then i create the model just
by passing the parameter file to it the
one I just showed you and now M is a
model i'm going to start that by sending
a command to the simulation right now
the simulation only has one command
start it has a pause command but because
we don't have the client working right
now the TK client it won't do anything
because you're blocked by this but um
and and then it'll run so in the future
you can use the command line carousel to
do a lot more so a ser Miang time
perfectly on time it's amazing okay so
this is the roadmap and I didn't really
prioritizes I mean it's great when you
have an open source project like this
that's funded by a corporation right but
that also means that the things I get to
work on are entirely dictated by my boss
you know and so but there are so many
great ideas a validation layer is one
that comes up for me all the time I I
made a model and it's not loading why
isn't loading right well it should be
easy for carousel to say you know you
forgot to specify all the arguments here
or you didn't give units for that and
say that you didn't want to use units a
testing layer so we talked about earlier
how people weren't doing unit testing
Django has a great built-in testing
layer I think that you should be able to
just say from your command line carousel
test and it should run all your tests
you should should be able to mock inputs
you know like
has fixtures a data scrubber layer for
people like us scrubbing data is
important and here I kind of merge two
things together I think it should be
easier there should be a nice well
documented API how do I make a new layer
how do i extend carousel like you know
just go through these steps boom now you
have an extension obviously the client
server is is a big push for me I want to
be able to start a carousel process and
then just communicate to it through
sockets so that it could be anywhere so
I mean we could also use MP right and
you could just do it locally on your
machine that's fine that would work too
oh right now everything is taking a
dictionary and one idea i had is well
why don't we do what django does and
other serializers make those fields and
what that does is in a dictionary I
could add any key i wanted to write and
nobody's going to say that's not a valid
key right but if you make it a field
it's like a class and then it will fix
that automatically these last 2 i've
already done so i've cleaned up a lot of
the names and reorganized classes i've
added new readers so there's an hdf5
reader there's a database no there isn't
it so these two aren't done API and
database but there is a django reader
and an argument reader and I'd like it
to work better with pandas and like
sequel alchemy other or m's and stuff
like that right now it only works with
Django uncertainty rappers is what you
were asking about so basically we needed
a way to propagate uncertainty I tried
everything the uncertainties package
algo pi numbed if tools all of those
require you to change your code right or
they don't work on C extensions
third-party libraries that you can't
change the code are you going to do that
so what we did was we estimate the
jacobian using central difference
approximation works you can go to the
website I ran a bunch of tests and there
are cases where it doesn't do a great
job very few cases but there are some
most of the time it's great and like I
said it's better than nothing right you
can preface it and say it's a jacobean
estimate right using central
difference he uses that cube root
approximation anyway so I've edited
against these guys and it works great
it's available on pi PI there's
documentation you can also collaborate
on github and I'm done thank you very
much any questions yes I haven't pathos
yeah since I developed uncertainty
rapper you know you go through like you
know message boards and bug lists and
I've heard so many people rolled their
own so I'm not surprised that there are
you said it was out of MIT
Mike Witts it's nothing okay thank you
very much any other questions anybody
think that they might actually use this
for a big modeling project
it's in the calculations so the
calculation layer has two calculators
you can extend this there's a static
calculator and a dynamic calculator it
does the static calculations first and
then the dynamic calculations in the
simulation calls those two calculators
and so what it does is it just after
it's done the topographical sort and
figure out what the order of the
calculations is it just calls each one
and then it's reading from there what
formula should I use and then it grabs
that formula out of the dictionary that
formula is an object Python objects
already been instantiated it's ready to
go all you have to do is shove in your
objects and get them out
um
so it's calling your formulas right so
it's calling them serially one after
another and then it plugs them into the
into the registry and then it will get
it back at the next so it's just looping
over the time steps doesn't solve the
time steps implicitly just one after the
other yeah for the dynamic part you
could add a different calculator so
that's the dynamic calculator that's
what it does right now if you want it to
add like an implicit time space
calculator then you could add that as
well so that would be in the calculation
layer you just overload the calculator
subclass or class super class and then
you could add that that's a great idea I
mean I wanted to basically make like a
nonlinear calculator anyway okay I think
we're done thank you everybody